[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ce nouveau numéro de 7,8 débat
balances ton port hashtag moi aussi la
sphère du producteur hollywoodien harvey
weinstein a eu l'effet d'un détonateur
mondial pour les femmes victimes de
harcèlement des voix qui aujourd'hui
s'élèvent sur twitter ou ailleurs pour
dire stop et briser l'omerta pourtant le
harcèlement sexuel ou moral envers les
femmes ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
alors que fait de l'exécutif pour lutter
contre que dit la loi
comment libérer la parole des femmes et
une fois que la parole se libère qu'en
faire c'est le débat du jour est avec
nous en plateau ce soir m e thibault a
bein delvolvé êtes avocat au barreau de
versailles et spécialiste en droit
public et agnès cordonnier vous êtes
membre de l'association créée activé
vous êtes chef d'une petite entreprise
bonsoir à tous les deux bien venu sur ce
plateau à nice cordonnier je me tourne
vers vous pour commencer cette émission
vous avez été victime de harcèlement
sexuel dans votre carrière c'était il y
a quinze ans vous étiez dans la fonction
publique
comment est ce que vous avez dénoncé
votre agresseur vous êtes tourné fait
vers votre hiérarchie
pour commencer oui tout à fait c'était
il y un peu plus de 15 ans
oui absolument g j'ai informé ma
hiérarchie
ça a été compliqué pour me faire
entendre bout de 2
de plusieurs tentatives en fait on a
imposé une confrontation
votre regard c'est très douloureux mais
écoutez ça c'est ça s'est soldé par un
blâme en fait et quand même
à l'époque mme johanne blâme c'est à
dire pour la wii voilà pour moi non plus
alors bon de mon côté à moi je ne vous
cache pas que j'ai j'ai quand même fait
le choix de répondre à une demande pour
une autre mission ailleurs alors que
j'étais très attaché à l'émission
j'étais en pleine évolution de carrière
et donc ça m'a ça m'a quand même coûté
100 que cette personne a eu un blâme
mais elle est à l'essai voilà ton baiser
à rester dans ses fonctions
oui tout à fait c'est normal enfin
comment est ce que vous vous voyez ça m
sur cette situation c'est cette personne
a eu un blâme elle continue d'exercer
la personne la victime est pénalisé
parti voilà dont évidemment présenté
comme ça c'est pas normal puisque vous
avez subi une situation qui est illégal
elle est il légal à la fois au regard du
code pénal alors peut-être qu'elle
n'était pas pénalement répréhensible
dans les mêmes conditions il ya quinze
ans qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui et elle
est illégale au sens également du code
du travail mais aussi pour vous dans la
situation où vous étiez d'agents publics
au sens de la loi qui régit le statut
d'agent public du 13 juillet 1983
donc c'est pas normal et on peut
également critiqué le niveau de sanction
qui est un blâme sanctions parmi les
plus légères qui existe dans l'arsenal
des sanctions des agents publics pour
sanctionner des faits aussi graves
alors la difficulté qu'ils existent
parfois c'est une difficulté de preuve
du harcèlement des faits de harcèlement
donc je connais pas la situation lequel
vous étiez vous est-ce que la preuve des
faits de harcèlement notamment de leur
caractère répété avait pu être établi
s'ils avaient si elle n'avait pas pu
l'être
on peut peut-être expliquer cette
sanction d'un niveau je dirais très
symbolique mais lorsque la preuve est
établie et l'eau d'ailleurs a coulé sous
les ponts depuis
l'arsenal
juridique s'est renforcée et on a
aujourd'hui pour des faits de même
nature des sanctions disciplinaires qui
sont autrement plus consistante qu'un
simple blâme alors quand on regarde un
petit peu les chiffres sur le
harcèlement au travail
une femme sur cinq est confronté à une
situation de harcèlement sexuel au cours
de sa vie professionnelle et seulement 5
% des cas sont portés devant la justice
alors question les lois sont elles
efficaces et suffisamment dissuasives
les lois sont aujourd'hui suffisamment
en tout cas clair puisque elles
établissent une définition relativement
large relativement souple du harcèlement
moral ce qui permet au juge qui
finalement doit trancher une situation
comme celle-là de partir de fait de
qualifier juridiquement les faits qui
sont qui lui sont rapportés bon ensuite
il ya je le disais à l'instant une
problème de preuve mais on a quelques
exemples quand même assez retentissant
d'ailleurs de condamnations pour
ces faits de harcèlement moral pour la
nation au plan pénal
bien sûr mais condamnation mais c'est
aussi au plan disciplinaire
j'ai l'exemple sous les yeux d'un d'un
ministre plénipotentiaire l'ambassadeur
de france dans une ambassade à
l'étranger qui s'était comporté avec le
personnel féminin avec de façon répétée
avec des allusions à connotation
sexuelle qui avait s'était acharné sur
une subordonnée de façon répétée cet
agent la a été tout ambassadeur qu'il
était sanctionné disciplinairement
c'était en 2013 un autre exemple
c'était une femme également harcelé
sexuellement par un homme ou des
messages e-mail lui avaient été
adressées d'abord de façon assez légère
sur ses tenues vestimentaires sur soie
façon de s'habiller de se coiffer
c'était relativement anodin et puis
c'est allé crescendo et on a finalement
constaté que
il a fini par lui faire des avances
sexuelles par mail il s'agissait de la
seconde professionnelle et il est allé
c'était finalement la goutte d'eau qui a
fait déborder le vase pour elle jusqu'à
une agression physique
cet argent là aussi a été sanctionné
donc on arrivait c'était là c'était en
2015 donc on aboutit à des situations
qui peuvent être sanctionnés et clips
des questions mails sms genre de preuve
c'est exactement ce genre de preuve oui
qui peut laisser mais ce témoignage de
deux bouts de voisins de témoignages de
proches de collègues qui peuvent
permettre d'établir ces situations en
tout cas c'est à dire en droit à nice
cordonnier quand vous avez dénoncé cette
personne votre agresseur est ce que vous
vous êtes senti soutenu par votre
hiérarchie soutenu par le système
judiciaire
qu'est ce qui a manqué système
judiciaire si traiter en interne avec la
direction de l'établissement
non je me suis pas sentie soutenue
puisque qu'est ce qui vous a manqué en
fait
on a on a plutôt désigné comme celle qui
avait déclenché sans si vous voulez donc
moi j'ai très mal effectué sans quand
j'ai fait la démarche en premier lieu on
me dit clairement que si c'était
certainement de la faute il y avait
certainement une attitude de mon côté et
c'est donc non j'ai pas eu le sentiment
d'avoir été entendu ça a été compliqué
alors juste vous êtes victime
vous vous remettez en question sur cette
démarche est ce que je dois avouer ce
que je dois en parler à mes hiérarchie
maître thibault a dit d'évoluer le
projet doit de marlène schiappa
secrétaire d'état à l'égalité des femmes
et des hommes
est-ce que ce projet peut changer la
donne et engager des femmes à porter
plainte justement parce que si si elles
se disent ma voix sera entendue
davantage est ce que ça peut pousser
certaines femmes à parler parce que ce
que vous disiez à madame c'était vous
vous décrivez en fait la mécanique de
l'enfermement de la part du harcelés et
on connaît une autre mécanique qui l'a
le miroir c'est la mécanique du
sentiment d'impunité du harceleur et ce
qui se produit dans ces cas là c'est
finalement le sentiment
de la victime qu'elle est finalement
l'auteur des fsi qui lui arrive et c'est
ce qui peut faire peut-être vous ça n'a
pas été le cas mais qui peut être fait
obstacle pour certaines victimes à la
dénonciation des faits dont elles sont
pourtant victimes et je dirais que pour
mettre fin à la spirale de l'enfermement
qui peut se produire parfois les
mécaniques qui semblent essentielles
sont d'abord le caractère public donc
l'information sur ces situations de
harcèlement moral alors s'en allait
peut-être jusqu aux excès que vous avez
dénoncé
donc vous avez en tout cas décrits au
départ balance temporel et c'est qui qui
a un caractère très stigmatisant et tout
ce qui est excessif finalement est
toujours assez assez assez néfaste
puisque ça va souvent trop loin mais il
est nécessaire quand même que
l'information vis-à-vis des victimes
existent premier la première chose puis
ensuite les dispositifs d'accès au droit
qui existe aujourd'hui dans le sur le
théâtre national des maisons d'accès au
droit
les points d'information de droits
permettent effectivement victime de
d'avoir une oreille attentive une
oreille non seulement un soutien moral
mais également un soutien juridique
puisque des avocats viennent faire des
permanences dans ces points d'accès au
droit est finalement peuvent de façon
tout à fait neutre indépendante entendre
les situations qui sont celles-là et
éventuellement leur donner une
qualification juridique de harcèlement
moral
et si ça n'est pas le droit qui peut
résoudre la chose il ya également
d'autres dispositifs qui peuvent être
mis en oeuvre soient internes à
l'employeur en l'occurrence et l
administration
il existe des dispositifs comme ce comme
cela ceux qui ont été mis en place dans
votre cas je pense était à fait
inadaptée puisque finalement d'entre
elles n'ont pas satisfait vous et ils
n'ont pas permis surtout que là l'auteur
sans doute soit suffisamment sanctionné
mais je pense notamment aux dispositifs
comme la médiation les modes alternatifs
de règlement des conflits qui peuvent
aussi permettre de libérer la parole
plus en profondeur que ne le fait à une
simple décision justice alors très
rapidement il nous reste trois minutes
d'émission
agnès cordonnier quand vous avez vous
avez dénoncé cette personne voilà on
libère la parole des femmes ont puni et
après est ce qu'il y à un accompagnement
quels accompagnements yat-il parce qu il
ya des femmes préjudice pour la santé
précarité car pertes d'emplois pour
certaines places certaines femmes quels
accompagnements il y a pour ces femmes
victimes d'harcèlement
en ce qui me concerne il n'y a pas eu de
l'accompagnement mais bon moi j'ai
beaucoup d'énergie une force de vivre en
moins c'est ce qui m'a permis je pense
dali en tout cas de de dénoncer un
meilleur art shing aussi voilà mais j'ai
trouvé en fait mes ressources yvonne et
je les ai trouvés dans cette autre
mission parce que c'est devenu un enfer
à partir de nantes il ya eu sanction
entre guillemets mais mon quotidien au
travail et vous pour accomplir ma
mission est devenue un enfer c'est à
dire que ça se passait vraiment rayman
avec cette personne donc effectivement
j'ai répondu à une sollicitation pousser
pour aller travailler ailleurs
ici ce qui m'a permis de rebondir aussi
alors pour pour conclure un mot chacun
sûr j'aimerais donner un petit peu votre
aux gars que le regard que vous portez
sur ces paroles de femmes qui se libère
avec elias les hashtag vous trouvez ça
c'est une matière en vous vous l'avez
dit juste avant mais j'aimerais avoir un
peu votre avis pour conclure cette
émission sur ses paroles
voilà trente secondes chacun ses paroles
ne sont pas en elle-même
on n'a pas de jugement de valeur a porté
là dessus ce sont des témoignages qui
sont des témoignages souvent sincère et
qui traduisent la façon dont les choses
ont été vécus si elles ont été vécue de
façon violente elle s'exprime de façon
violente
il n'y a pas de jugement de valeur a
porté là dessus simplement la société ne
doit pas dans un emballement médiatique
tirer prétexte de l'existence des
dénonciations comme établissant des
vérités notamment des vérités
judiciaires puisque le travail de la
justice un travail non travail qui
établit avec d'équitable et des vérités
avec des preuves et donc ce que je
trouve cette stigmatisation fait qu
tivement c'est le fait que l'on puisse
jeter en pâture des noms de personnes
qui peut-être ont été des harceleurs et
peut-être pas et c'est à la justice de
le déterminer petit soldat
donc je pense que moi j'ai bien dit
toutes les femmes à parler je veux dire
si c'est un problème à ne pas rester
comme ça parce que voilà après ça crée
un trou menace est claire et donc il ya
un travail à faire sur soi mais il faut
pas attendre que ça soit trop grave
merci à tous les deux d'être venu sur ce
plateau fin de cette émission ce soir
consacrée au harcèlement et à la parole
des femmes
l'émission est à revoir sur notre site
internet a commenté sur les réseaux
sociaux facebook twitter instagram
bonsoir à tous et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]